[Music]
oh welcome to the creek in the cave
two things before we get started please
stay off your cell phones no heckling
and keep cable talk to a minimum now
who's ready for other people
[Music]
well you know you love them give it up
to your hosts Hans Kim
[Music]
hello Austin Texas it's good to be here
in the home of live music
you know music is related to dating a
lot a lot of people date with music so
this is a great City for dating where
there's a lot of romance in the air
tonight
well we're gonna have a great time uh we
got Nick Roche on the keys
that's what I call the sound board it's
the keys
I don't know why I did that Tywin in the
house
he's Asian
uh but this is not just a show about
Asians it's also show about white men
and my next guest is a very white man
very beautiful beautiful soul and a
funny comedian please get up for Gareth
Fisk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Gareth welcome to the show how is your
dating life oh my dating wife's going
pretty well right now Hans I'd say so
awesome man yeah don't brag
I'll try not to
I can't wait to have people up here and
judge them relentlessly though that
white man thing is very true I don't
know if you could tell that uh by the
way Gareth um you recently invited me to
go biking what was that all about uh
white guy activities
um it's either that or golf uh in
general but it would have been a nice
bike ride today what would we do on a
bike ride together you just stare at my
ass or I'd stare at your ass you know
it's pretty cool we actually ride
together at the same time and take up
the whole Lane and I have a little
ringer and then when people get too
close they go ring ring ring ring and
then sometimes they yell at ladies I'm
like ring ring ring ring
anyway invited me to a bicycle ride with
bells on it I thought it would be like
cool mountain bikes or BMX let's get
[ __ ] bro
uh you know uh you know there's nothing
wrong with that I'm a little gay hey so
what how's about that how's about that
you guys I'm also obnoxiously straight
so what a beautiful straight man we have
tonight thank you you're beautiful too
Hans
give it up for Gareth Fisk our guest of
the evening
look
foreign
straight female coming up interview for
60 seconds and then we are a date for 60
seconds and then we interview you we got
Jacqueline P coming up
from front and center
stairs are right around the corner in
that direction this way Jackson she goes
Jacqueline p as confused as Jacqueline
Onassis during the JFK assassination uh
and then we got chatto coming up
Chad oh shadow
human male come on Chad
we got Shadow other pretty lady waiting
up here hurry it up it's been on this
show before
give it up for Chad guys
[Applause]
date for 60 seconds starting now with
the Michael oh nice to meet you nice to
meet you is it Chad o or Shadow I've
been putting it together as one but okay
yeah nice to meet you thanks you look
very nice tonight thank you you've
planned on this or did you end up here
wait what was that did you plan on
coming here would you end up here
um we planned we planned that's cool me
and my friend oh you bought tickets
online I thought this would be fun yeah
yeah what about you no I I hang out here
oh okay you just like hang out in the
corner yeah is it just actually your
name that's in the bucket yeah switch
them out like
and try your lucky show well I Go by
different names so it does help okay
okay nice but uh so what do you do
um I work in IT consulting how about you
that's very common on this show it seems
like that's a Sunday thing to do it's an
Austin thing for sure at least now it is
yeah yeah that's cool what about you I I
uh I try to be a comic I own some online
businesses I've been a writer I do a lot
of different things okay what what are
some online businesses that you own so I
sell drugs online
at time
give it up for a shadow and Jacqueline p
ey Channel you sell drugs online I try
to stay legal drugs but you know so you
sell like Adderall and Zoloft mostly
like CBD right now but yeah uh CBD
Jacqueline P are you boring or do you
also not smoke CBD
no THC hell yeah
Shadow you got blown out of the water
just I smoke a lot of weed I just sell a
lot of CBD yeah
I don't smoke CBD he's got to sell CBD
to pay for the THC now now she
understood we're connecting here yeah
that's uh way to go you should actually
just sell THC because you can sell a lot
more of it yeah but you can't do it
online because it actually works I agree
100 drugs on the Silk Road right does
that still exist the black market yeah
selling drugs works a lot better person
to person I would say see that's what
I'm saying yeah just a little helpful
advice yeah just get it on just get on
internet show let them know you sell CBD
and then see me after the show Shadow
internet drug dealer this is what they
look like now
this is like when the bar regular is
hitting on someone he shouldn't be
hitting on
that might be correct guys oh when the
age-old question uh just like death and
taxes comes up what do you do do not
answer that question with oh I sell
drugs online
uh that's just prob just a little
helpful advice there but you look like
you just buy drugs online I maybe I do
maybe I do
so anyways yeah you look like you sell
him drugs online and then he his parents
sue you because you killed him that
might be a thing
I don't think he does that Chad seems
not that nice no fit in all my CBD I'm a
good guy Jacqueline P how does it feel
to be on stage with three handsome men
thank you for including me it's really
making my Sunday that much better
well welcome to Austin
the autism here is top notch
how is it working in IT consulting as a
woman do you deal with a lot of autists
no because you have to be a consultant
so you have to have like some level of
social skills yeah I don't work at
Google you can't be too good at coding
try to consult
uh you gotta be a little dumb I got a
question who ordered the Lacroix first
and goes I want one too
who's the first great question Shadow
what a fabulous question Shadows you
both uh down to the Lacroix here what
are you drinking liquor yeah Shadow
you've been on this Shadow you've been
on the show a couple times has any of
these dates worked out for you I have
four Instagram followers now
wow congratulations shadow
so uh what do you think usually works on
this show and why didn't you do any of
it today
I'm trying to be myself more now I think
I think I was a little nervous the first
couple times I was I was trying to do
magic and you know oh yeah Shadow was
big into magic for like three weeks
and then he just stopped doing it yeah
it wasn't as impressive I was told that
last one didn't work so well so I I
almost hug myself doing magic during a
date is a great way not to get laid
that's what I thought was a good
Icebreaker but you're right no it's
that's that's a horror wise breaker dude
nobody wants to see that I always think
it's a risky move to tell someone that
they look nice today because then if
they don't say it back it means that
they don't think you look nice I
understand the reason not to say it back
not 100 I uh but it's just being honest
you're just saying whatever's whatever
you're thinking
I might be on your scale bro I'm trying
but if you're if you're just sitting
here now what would you say to
Jacqueline P something that you noticed
just off the top of your head I like
your curly hair
oh my god oh it's wavy hair
Sparks are flying
Sparks are falling that was the
creepiest thing you could have said
Sparks it would have been creepier if he
asked to smell it
but I could yes that is every woman
had someone try to smell their hair at
some point oh what was the last time a
dude tried to smell your hair High
School okay that was a while ago we're
young and horny it's not our fault
what I said when they're sitting in
front of you on the in the chair you
just no yeah that guy was there's
definitely something wrong with that guy
it's just
sniffing hair where do you think that
guy is now you think he's in jail
no I think he's in Oregon
oh she keeps I think she's in Oregon
specifically somewhere in Oregon I don't
know Oregon is like jail for cool people
you go there
you go there if you're anti-social you
got to do mushrooms all the time
that's cool how did he uh how did he do
how did he pull off this maneuver did he
just lean forward in the desk like
Shadow just expertly showed us
no I think we were walking to school and
I think he was touching everyone's hair
and he thought mine was soft and then he
just kind of
that's totally not a move I'm gonna do
tonight at the bars
I'm a little kid touching everyone's
hair
what's his name uh by chance Joe Biden
you know I can't quite remember okay he
just called you old uh
sorry Hunter Biden
oh my God
Shadow what's the uh what's the what's
the nicest way that you've ever like
shown interest in a woman maybe in high
school as a child do you have any
flowers out yes I uh I was more of a
stalker I have put flowers on girls cars
before like put put in their Windows
where do the wise Shadow if you're on a
date don't mention at one point you were
a stalker yeah
solid advice from Gareth Fisk
I give it out but yeah I wrote poems to
girls I had my art teacher right or I
had my art teacher paint a portrait of
my girlfriend and uh you commissioned
her yeah I commissioned it yes and he
was also your teacher yes and he charged
me 200 bucks for this oh god wow and it
wasn't that great milking children
this guy's setting up
teenagers to [ __ ] each other
I was like I'm gonna use my art to
enhance teen pregnancy
Jacqueline p uh did you uh ever meet
anyone in college
how what what do you do now you you just
out of college or are you like
old you don't she's you don't remember
what my profession was you're in I.T
Consulting yeah very vague by the way it
is
but I'm not in college it's the least
I.T of all the I.T fields
probably
yes so um yeah so how how long how how
have you hit on someone at your job
maybe
get on guys or what do you like that
girl it's like hey what's going on yeah
you ever leave a flower on some dude's
car
do you even leave a note or do you just
leave a creepy ass flower I left a poem
I wrote a poem Oh God
okay you should have just left no note
you should have said I don't do any of
those things but he's wrong once more
just [ __ ] swinging for the fences out
here chatto I'm I'm I'm I'm a nice
honest person that's beautiful give it
up for Chad Hill everybody he's a nice
honest person we love that we love you
thank you okay thank you uh Jacqueline
so uh what's the best way to hit on
someone in I.T Consulting
through chat
tell them they have really clean code oh
yo your your code looks like it doesn't
have any STDs
there are no bugs in the back door of
her code
that was a good I.T joke you guys
Gareth looks like he should work in I.T
I I kind of a deal man
you look like you could manage an I.T
from that your dad gifted you
hey you guys you have to laugh harder my
dad actually owns this bar so
Shadow what does your dad do
he's a deadbeat dad yeah divorced at
four some occasionally must run in the
family let me tell you about Chad once
more on a first date let's not talk bad
about parents not a good what's the best
thing about your dad something he did
right
for my uh eighth birthday he bought a
2500 Batman costume instead of me a
birthday present and dressed up as
Batman
for my birthday 2 500 worth of Batman
costume yeah I did not give you a
present did he have a Batmobile that was
just a blacked out van
no I had to pick him up from the airport
that week all right
was he ever like
I don't know a Batman reference but I
was gonna make it about child
molestation grapple hook
does it feel like a grapple hook in your
[ __ ]
um Shadow so I think he just wanted to
buy a Batman costume and it happened to
be your birthday correct my birthday's
October 29th yeah about how your dad
doesn't care about you correct
Jacqueline P how uh hello
how long have your parents been together
because they're obviously not divorced
you're right my both my parents were
there for me
um good job Jacqueline
good job stay together for the kids or
they're owned up like Shadow yeah
um I think
the 29 years
whoa 29 years it's older than me that's
crazy
I wouldn't have known that
you can get to know it he's like we're
the same age we should totally date
that's cool you come from a good family
nice picket fence little dog
medium dog medium dog no pick it Ben
what do you think they would say if you
brought Shadow home for Thanksgiving and
he came on a little Hurley
they say 20s are for learning
I could teach you a few things
this has become the roast of Shadow
thank you thank you for showing up
Shadow not a lot of people know this but
Shadow is actually married
what else can we say on this day to not
make it work come on he didn't mention
it though that's a plus for him today I
think that's the best thing that's been
said about you tonight is that you're
married I've actually been married about
as long as her parents I've been married
23 years
oh yeah wow how [ __ ] old are you man
I'm 23. in my in my religion this is how
you do it why are you sitting alone
because I've been married 23 years I'm
on a dating show
do you do you think your parents ever go
to dating shows and date random
strangers or is that just a shadow thing
I think her parents are happy
no my mom definitely cheated on my dad
whoa
[Music]
whoa all's not right in the world of the
whites
so she understands where we're coming
from oh wait Shadow let's tell us tell
us about the time your mom cheated uh it
wasn't my mom it was her mom no no I
know that Chad I wasn't talking to you
Jacqueline yes I mean you don't have to
answer that but I'd love to hear shame
Live on YouTube by the way
but that's a cool story did you see it
tell this story
how do you know
he got added to my car insurance oh
your mom [ __ ] Jake from State Farm
so to anyone out there who's trying to
cheat don't add your Affair partner to
your child's car insurance
wow your mom dead giveaway here Mom
knows how to flirt in an I.T Consulting
business that is
that is how you get to first base in the
I.T Consulting world
I could totally add you to my car
insurance
that is some white [ __ ]
it can get wider yes but
uh no uh Jacqueline you've been so kind
up here you don't have to this is a hot
that's we don't want to pick on you we
don't want to have to go into these
stories but uh yeah no tell us more
about what you hate about work
what do you hate about work
um work I want to hear more about her
mom [ __ ]
or that yeah it's a broke ass loser
which one your friend looks so concerned
for you right now I think she's loving
it
yeah all right well hell yeah that's
good tell us something about yeah your
mom [ __ ] a stranger
I don't know I think
no I have nothing funny to say about it
it's not really a fun situation well
luckily they're still married now and
they're probably not gonna see this
unless someone says it yeah stopped so
that's the only positive you think she
stopped do you think it could still be
going on that means that's damn her dad
should come on the show
[Laughter]
I date you no I just know where he's
coming from
I just get it you know
oh God Chad we've never had a daughter
and father combo on this show before but
hopefully it doesn't happen I hope not
just show up on alternating weeks
Jacqueline with your dad
I don't think they want to come to Texas
where are they cheating on each other at
what state
California that's where it would happen
those goddamn liberals
I don't ain't got no soul out there
California
Shadow have you uh you're in an open
relationship right how does that work
with your wife pretty much like her
parents her parents you just you just
find out one day and you're like oh we
are okay thanks so I go on dating shows
though that's kind of cool you know
this isn't good for you man no this is
not Gareth is sad for you that's all
right I mean sympathy helps doesn't it
no yeah but give it up for Chad
relationship it's an ice oh he's an
honest nice guy guys
that's two Zippity collabs this episode
okay last question how did you hurt your
finger
all right so I I literally cut the top
of it off by bringing your wife's dry
ass [ __ ] no no she stays wet she has a
lot of guys uh but I was moving some
stuff in the garage and I literally
chopped the top of it off so I I think I
glued it on the right way but I glued
the shade on and taped it on oh my God
he does his own surgeries yeah yeah and
he sells his own CBD so he can feel all
the pain yeah I put the CBD on it put
some blue on it I'm good to go oh yeah
Dragon what do you think about this
manly man who knows his way around tools
but not that well
I think you're okay
oh give it up for Shadows Jacqueline p
he's got another date up here
we got a straight male named ish smiley
oh Smiley coming up from did someone get
me a white claw as well and uh Natasha C
Natasha see
foreign
are very intoxicated guests I haven't
had one beverage tonight Natasha C
coming up
going on a daytime Ishmael and Ishmael
hello hello ish Smiley it actually
Ismail but uh I gentrified my name
all right give it up for Natasha C and
ish Smiley come on guys giving on up
[Applause]
starting now
hello
hey what brings you to Austin
um
the flights were cheap I'm from
California I said why not nice is it
your first time being out here
and what do you think of Boston
um it's okay you know
ouch
right
are you from here um so I'm actually
from like the Border essentially
I was born in Mexico and uh as as as one
does we cross the border you know
and uh yeah I've been here for 28 years
now or 26 years
I was two when I came here oh okay
all right um what do you do for work or
like what do you do for fun
uh I'm a nurse
so that's not fun
um
it can be I guess right uh cool
um how old are you
I'm 26. oh nice you look a lot younger
than that
and time give it up for ish Smiley and
Natasha see I was gonna say you're 25.
thank you with the numerical complement
love it dude as an Asian I respect that
you look like you could be
14. uh
anyways
ish Smiley you recently said that you
crossed the border well not recently oh
but I mean you recently said it but it
happened a while ago I was a baby I
don't remember was it legal or illegal
and just a reminder there's a man with a
cowboy hat right there ready to take you
back if you answer incorrectly it was
most definitely illegal whoa
[Applause]
for this child felon
so uh yeah you're uh your how's uh how's
life been how's the uh how's the old
Border doing
uh I like it just because it's cheap
it's a cheap place to live yeah I bought
like two acres of land for two thousand
dollars [ __ ] yeah it's a smart ass
investment-ish well yeah give it up for
him it's a landowner y'all yeah we had
we have to find a spot to keep all my
cousin sick you know when they come over
we got it we gotta have somewhere to put
them
come on take ahead y'all that's a lot of
cousins
two thousand acres of cousins
it's easy for us to fill it up you know
so uh how does that work do you just
like walk across and just
uh it's a fun story uh post 911 uh it
was easy to cross the border all the
time but well yeah I mean that's not
really known that much I would think
it's harder after 9 11. I met before but
yeah now it's impossible the best
stories always start with post 911.
a post 911 but anyway 911 Crosser
that's cool man you own land I'm a legal
resident and I don't own land what the
[ __ ]
we're rich as hell too Hans look at this
[ __ ] yeah I could buy 17 acres
and
store 14 14 000 cousins
Natasha see you how's uh being a nurse
and are you Filipino or are you just a
nurse uh
a lot of nurses are Filipino this is
very true uh I'm Filipino by association
does that count you're an honorary yeah
Filipino
I thought you were Asian I am okay
I don't know why I asked she's
definitely good looking and a nurse that
fits the role give it up for Natasha
absolutely what a queen
slay Queen absolutely uh Natasha you
said nursing is not fun
what makes it what's the least fun thing
that you do
nursing uh socialize
socialize don't you have to clean up poo
poo and stuff like that dude yeah but I
gotta say hey turn it over
I like Natasha more and more
ish Smiley got a little hard when she
said that
I uh I walked up here hard already so
what are you talking about
it's okay I've seen plenty
oh
it's getting spicy
a little balut it's getting on here but
it's because I'm wearing two shirts
what is what that move why are you
wearing two shirts uh y'all gotta check
it out
creep crept keeper dick all right
I didn't notice that until now Ishmael
here word up good advice for you don't
go to a date with a shirt that says
Crypt Keeper dick
in Big Bowl letters with what is that a
[ __ ] vampire skull on your [ __ ]
shirt that's our boy Tyler what are you
doing man also awareness it looks like
it looks like a uh Colts hat from the
gas station dude
the [ __ ] are you doing man I'm hiding my
receding hairline my bad
is your hairline really receding let us
see it oh
don't you don't look I'm I'm not I'm not
ashamed of it oh there we go give it up
let's go
oh I smell slays I wear it because I
don't want to do my hair right [ __ ] stop
it looks like your hair is trying to
cross the border too
it crossed the border already like years
ago bro border of acceptability
uh uh Natasha C so uh are you here
legally or illegally
oh that was a horrible question
this is how we talk
so don't say we okay
we're not out here asking people if
they're legal or not I can't also do
that it's not it's not a good fit for me
so
let us see your papers please
having flash I don't have a German
[ __ ] accent man
what the hell that's Texas I'm not the
goddamn bad guy from Die Hard the [ __ ]
you're dressed like him dude you're
dressed like I am no no patriarchy today
dressed like James Bond not the villain
why are you trying to make me happy you
look like James Bond's manager
I'll take that thank you give it up for
James Bond's manager you guys I'll tell
you that was horrible I'm sorry I won't
obey the old Cloud for that
I didn't mean to okay thanks for that
Gareth
um yeah Natasha C what do you usually
look for on a date
um well
I have a boyfriend but my friend put my
name in the bucket so I had to come up
uh who's your friend
right there
hey friends no one looking behind that
means you're coming up next it's an old
rule on other people it's okay I have a
boyfriend too
oh yeah he just doesn't know it yet
[Applause]
his sense of humor is intact but I file
my taxes single so
oh it ain't official to the IRS knows
about it
exactly
true Asian way of dating
have you added anyone to your car
insurance
I'm still on my father's
okay
not going into that uh it's okay I just
started paying him
started paying him
uh that's cool so yeah you're you're uh
have you ever added anyone to your
Netflix or your HBO GO is that uh is
that how nurses flirt uh no I am
actually a leech so I just hop on other
people's plans
nice a leech yes you know what that was
does you're a nurse yeah you can't be
leeching people or pads we don't do
witchcraft in Texas what's going on
we're past that is that what you apply
to people when you take their blood
okay
um
it's a valid question
ish Smiley how does it feel to be on a
date with a nurse Mike's my ex was a
nurse Nick you
take care of babies
she yeah I mean
so you hear you so this is no big deal
for you yeah I mean I guess I guess I
mean we're exes for a reason right but
what does she do oh it was me I was a
[ __ ] I didn't want to like live with
her
uh you're willing to live in Mexico but
you're not willing to live with your
[ __ ]
I have to work for it right but
anyway so you're afraid of commitment I
used to yeah not anymore now you're
desperate
yeah and I'm on a dating show I guess
yeah when somebody's got a boyfriend
all right Ishmael let's get some
Redemption tell us some redeeming
qualities about yourself
um
I'd like to think I'm funny
you're very funny
thank you what's the funniest thing that
you've done recently
uh I had this shirt on and uh me and Ty
were walking at Best Buy and the shirt
says I'm from Pflugerville [ __ ] and we
kept saying we got to go somewhere where
there's no kids I'm like bro I feel like
a pedophile
man let me tell you that was yeah
it was funny at the time you know no
money at the time I don't think it was
well I thought it was and that's what
matters not funny on a date
so what's the funniest pedophile joke
that you've ever heard
oh I don't write pedophile jokes that
was just a funny uh circumstance that's
a redeeming quality for most
the most part
Natasha C have you ever gotten a poem
from a dude uh yes I did
watch out for Chad chados been at it
again the rose poetry poet
uh so yeah what was that like how did it
make you feel
oh I liked it but I had a boyfriend
ah this boyfriend keeps [ __ ] blocking no
it was a different boyfriend oh okay
you're just jumping from boyfriend to
boyfriend uh Natasha oh it's a free
world you know what yeah I gotta find a
husband you do you do is it Ishmael
important
possibly
oh there we go I guess we'll never know
trying to help you out dog what's going
on man
yeah just dating is complicated right I
mean I think we all can agree
um what's the most complicated date that
you've ever been on
um
complicated that would mean like go on
dates uh
I I literally don't like go on dates
it's uh it's not a really uh it's not a
Target Rich environment at Best Buy
laughs
it was Walmart but I know but you know
what Ishmael let's let's let's do this
because if if Natasha doesn't go on a
second date is there any lady out there
that would want to go on a date with
Ishmael come on
oh I got a whoa who said that we're not
gonna make her commit or anything that's
good enough all right yeah there we go
give it up for Ishmael there was one
lady that said yes you can find him
after the show
he'll be the one reading a comic book at
the bar
[Laughter]
it's gonna be Hans with a wig
Natasha are you into any like nerdy
things like Marvel movies oh yes I just
got into it oh okay Ishmael this is your
chance what's a cool Marvel fact that
you can tell
so actually uh so so what happened was
uh I used to work at the movies and they
were coming out so often that I wanted
to put them aside and then one day my
friend's like dude there's like 20 of
them I'm like what the [ __ ] you know
like I didn't know there were so many
out there but uh I just recently started
watching them I really don't know
um but yeah if she's nerdier than you
are I wouldn't have expected I mean I
really like them but it's just something
that I it's not something I like paid
attention to no that was your time to
shine dude
could have been like you know Iron Man's
Cod piece is actually I mean I don't I
can't lie so I mean I'm just being
honest all right
yeah that's so nice dude come on
well thank you for coming on the on the
show anything you guys like to say to
each other before you part way did you
put your name on here oh someone put it
right yeah someone put my name on
YouTube oh I guess they're coming up
next yes yeah who is your friend that
put you up
Philly Birdo right there that guy I mean
I'm cool with it like I'm not shy but
okay what's his name Filiberto philberto
Philly Berto felly Berto yeah God damn
that's a name from South of the Border
that's that's where we know each other
we got Philly Berto coming up going on a
date with Natasha C's friend and her
name is Tiffany Tiffany Filibertos
hell yeah
[Applause]
make sure you're coming
Tiffany I thought uh it was the other
person
I wouldn't expect you to do this to your
friend
I thought you were a lot Kinder than
that
Filiberto I can see signing his friend
up is a bit of a rascal
Filiberto and Tiffany going to give it
up for the couple y'all come on
are
get it loud
time starts now hello
what's your what's your name Tiffany
it's a strong name
Filibertos
that's the that's the name they gave me
on the Social Security when I crossed
the border so
we're here
sticking with it yeah yeah
what's that tattoo about what's that
what's going on there
this um it says love I got it with a
friend I'm gonna get it covered up
because you know friends friends come
and go like this one over here
[Applause]
and what what language is that that's
not American Greek are you Greek no
okay was your boyfriend at the time a
Greek my girlfriend sorry boyfriend
girlfriend either
so what made you go agree that's
interesting
what's that about
cool cool
do you do drugs or anything is that what
that is
currently I feel that I feel that nice
and time give it up for Filiberto and
Tiffany
[Applause]
you know it's a bad tattoo when someone
sees it and then says do you do drugs
it's wild bro filiberta that's a risky
move
um what uh what what do you think about
uh tattoos do you have any I have a few
and they're just as shitty yeah
um I have a Texas flag right here
and then a moon slash Sun I can decide
so I got both we can we think matching
things I'm done tonight
you have prison tattoos yeah yeah they
look like they were drawn in pencil they
were they were sticking poke
um by a guy that was also on drugs at
the same time I was on drugs
you're like yeah so you were just being
like are you one of us yeah
see what's up yeah you're a guy that
buttons his shirt all the way to the top
yeah I've seen that in movies yeah do
you have a car that bounces too
oh [ __ ] you're running over children in
it yeah
uh Tiffany what do you think about
Filiberto do you think that uh he's a
very Suave young Fidel Castro
definitely definitely I was gonna say
Che Guevara but yeah no if I see either
one of the commies in there
we're just here bro we're just here to
have a good time
filiberta why did you vote for Joe Biden
and are you vaccinated
foreign
but uh yes unfortunately I'm vaccinated
oh damn I think you're the only Trump
supporter that's named Filiberto
well okay uh so let's give it up for uh
Tiffany the third beautiful lady that
came out here tonight
what the [ __ ] Eric and then let's give
it up for Phil Roberto the uh third in
cell I've seen today we have about 40
School shooters in the room I think
right now sorry Miss Andreas that's
sexist against men we're not all School
shooters okay that's true Gareth uh what
do you think about this couple you think
that uh you know I could see them
walking their pit bulls together
for sure
totally
they're gonna get like eventually
they'll have a kid and then like uh
they'll get baby tattoos of like their
handprints on their wrists
probably uh jaded and a Brayden I'm
assuming
other Mike uh nephew's name so and my
cousin also so I have white trash in my
family that's fine yeah we could
definitely see you at a Buffalo Wild
Wings in the future
go Cowboys I'll see you there guys
actually Pluckers is much better but
that's another topic for debate I saw
Sparks uh this is the first interview we
had tonight where the what do you do
didn't come up
so that I give them brownie points for
that for sure
but what do y'all do are you employed or
what
I do sales uh for an internet company I
uh you sell drugs online too no no I buy
drugs online but no I don't don't sell
no not even sell things for an internet
company very very ambiguous answer there
uh internet sales internet sales
okay all right he's uh he's definitely
in the cartel or something
I really like Phil Roberto you guys he's
a really cool guy please don't murder us
sorry so nice
and Tiffany what do you do for a living
Emma at a restaurant wow so food sales
oh hell yeah you're working uh the
service industry yeah I've done like
every job in a restaurant so that's
pretty cool what restaurant do you work
at it's a
it's Puerto Rican yeah oh cool [ __ ] dude
you guys both look Puerto Rican
you guys could eat each other like we're
eating at a Puerto Rican restaurant
tonight like oral sex anyways uh
Tiffany so uh you work at this Puerto
Rican restaurant
are there a lot of uh you know cat
collars and Puerto Ricans
oh my God Hans this one time I don't
even remember this but we were at a bar
and uh they were these two girls that we
were talking to and you called there was
Puerto Ricans and he could he goes oh
[ __ ] so you're scored a Ricans huh and
they well they loved it they loved it
and they still are still in contact with
them and they ask about you so
I know about it I know how to talk to
Puerto Ricans
now
order freaking
uh Filiberto if you were at uh Tiffany's
Puerto Rican restaurant
how would you how would you like
initiate a conversation
oh why do you have such a shitty tattoo
oh my god dude
get the [ __ ] out of here with your all
the way buttoned up t-shirt man what the
hell I'm sorry God damn man that's not
the way you talk to a lady that's not
cool we're on a stage here all right
give it up for Tiffany she's [ __ ]
doing great up here so Roberto that was
just unnecessary and crude it was just
troll humor and it was vile okay
filiberta how do you feel right now uh
slightly nervous I'm not gonna lie I'm a
little very pretty girl she's a shitty
tattoo but she's a very pretty girl so
ah very nice uh tattoo purist he does
not compromise on tattoos the one under
on her finger is really pretty I like it
thank you that was that was nice that
was nice Phil Roberto say another
compliment to her tell her about how
nice her hair is say something nice
again very pretty eyes like they're far
apart but not way too far apart
doing what are those glasses dude you're
the shittiest look at John Lennon
impression I've ever seen the [ __ ] out
of here when was the last time you did
laundry [ __ ] three months ago Dude
why is that shirt so goddamn wrinkled
accurate [ __ ] you man she looks great
give it up for Tiffany you guys
thank you
thank you
[ __ ] you Phil Roberto
his glasses are a little foggy so maybe
he's not seeing right
probably that's accurate [ __ ]
four-eyed piece of [ __ ]
you look like Mexican Harry Potter
I've heard that
got a big broom
oh god dude
you have no no good things to say
let's all right man look just say a
[ __ ] compliment to Tiffany That's it
man and we I we will all redeem you we
will all look at you and say you know
what Phil Roberto that's a good guy
right now we're all going [ __ ] that dude
okay so say one thing nice to Tiffany
because she's a really sweet lady okay
she has really prettier and a pretty
small
all right that's exactly
wow good job Filiberto
I finally didn't say something weird
have fun uh being an inso uh Filiberto
what do you think about uh you know uh
your friend that would just went up ish
Smiley do you think you have any advice
for him they were [ __ ] friends
I oh [ __ ] that I wasn't dialed in on
that one that makes total sense there
okay
he
wait were you the guy that was wearing
the other dumbass t-shirt thing and you
were funny as [ __ ] in Walmart no okay
well
close enough
yeah
so uh how are you feeling what do you
think about uh dating in Austin or have
you been putting yourself out there
yeah I have a girlfriend right now so
yeah we're pretty much oh you have a
girlfriend yeah I didn't sign up at all
I'm used to it
yeah this is a typical oh what happened
what's your what's your story how are
you used to it elaborate
[Music]
on you I'm always a side really [ __ ]
those cheating [ __ ] you set yourself
up to be yourself I'm not a cheater I
just want to make that straight
everybody is that your like comfort zone
being like a side like yeah commitment
don't have to commit I get it I get it
yeah I mean filiberta you're uh you have
a girlfriend
he wants to
yeah that seemed their scene that was a
good that was a good segment that was a
back and forth there there okay you guys
that was good that was good God damn
it's like he's uh
these [ __ ] illegals have land they
have girlfriends they're taking
everything from me
uh Tiffany are you Puerto Rican or did
you just pass this Puerto Rican I passed
Puerto Rican oh hell yeah are you also
Filipino
by association
what is this Association of Filipinos
you guys have like a union or something
well give it up for these two people
that have signed up their friends they
went on a date and they had to do what
they thought they signed their friends
up to do can I have another uh alcoholic
Rambler or a white Club beverage please
and thank you Gareth having fun on other
people we got long time favorite we got
Cody coming up Cody
oh [ __ ] Cody look at that [ __ ]
scarf you got on your forehead dog
looking good as hell and the lady of the
evening Isabel
[Applause]
no last name is there you go Isabelle
going on a date with Cody hey yo
beautiful lady of the evening
Isabelle and Cody going on a date for
one minute starting now how's it going
it's going well how are you doing I'm
good I'm a little nervous but happy to
be here yes um I think I'm past being
nervous because this is like my one
social thing so I'm okay
uh Sunday's works for my schedule price
works for my wallet you know it's
convenient Hans is funny sometimes only
sometimes yeah okay did you try other
Sunday activities uh Church once but it
just kind of is a better job for you
yeah yeah Fair
it's kind of weird there's that whole
cannibalism thing
um I'm not into that this is my blood
okay yeah yeah I got you nice
um how about you do you do a lot of
Sunday activities uh yeah I do what do
you do on Sundays um I clean my house I
walk my dog I recover from the night
before fun stuff like that it's exciting
I I didn't mention that I I do beekeep
but not currently because it's sort of
too cold and it's the winter time and
the bees don't like to be bothered right
now it's not good for them and time give
it up for a Cody and Isabelle
how does it make you feel to know that
Cody is a beekeeper
intrigued but yeah
it's like a pretty cool hobby I'm trying
to get more into hobbies and I feel like
beekeeping is a pretty rare one it's
very
um fulfilling I should say I I do enjoy
it a lot [ __ ] super hot dude
[Laughter]
yeah I know I know a lot about sweet
stuff and I think you're sweet like
honey
I'll keep you buzzing
that was awful I'm so sorry you guys
have you met any women beekeeping
besides your mother
several yes but they tend to be my
mother's age so how do you uh like judge
people or like how do you like see if
you're physically attracted to someone
in the beekeeping world
[Laughter]
to wait until after you're done
beekeeping and take off the suit I
remember like damn I love how that net
fits around your curves
no because then it wouldn't work
[Laughter]
I have you ever heard of furries
furries do it all the time dude there's
a whole segment of people that are into
[ __ ] in a suit made of an animal you
can do it to by beekeeping suit I'm
sorry I don't know where I'm getting are
you one of those people
what huh
oh absolutely not
wait I was on your side what was your
name again I can't even remember my name
Isabel I'm gonna be honest with you guys
I kind of zoned out I took like 200
milligrams of an edible before a show I
knew that already yeah well it kicked in
right whenever y'all were talking
started talking so
Isabel what do you do I'm an
environmental consultant oh nice thank
you what do you have to say to these I.T
Consultants
I respect your industry
you know Consulting can be kind of a
[ __ ] and I feel like it takes a certain
kind of person
thank you
oh that was cute a message of peace
across Industries
uh you have a dog how's your dog doing
she's great
um I got her from APA like four months
ago she is super cute her name is
Delilah but she's also a [ __ ] Menace
um she likes to eat tampons the first
time was off the ground outside of
Walmart it was a used tampon not mine I
didn't thank you for clarifying
you're not just outside of Walmart I
don't throw my Tamp
could be a feminist thing it could be a
protest
people
and guard dog
it's a good thing that
you got a dog that bites people
I would not expect that I thought you
would have a Chihuahua or something I
don't like Chihuahuas but what about me
makes you think I would have a Chihuahua
your soft voice you know seemed very
like quiet
in this setting yes
what kind of dog do you think Cody would
have if he had a dog
retriever
yeah he's got golden retriever Vibes for
sure that's a safe bet
um I've only ever owned cats but I do
love dogs you definitely have more cat
energy
all my extended family is owned dogs so
I'm familiar with the medium to large
breeds
okay don't call them medium to large
breeds
just call them beautiful souls and furry
bodies
that's cool so uh yeah I mean you do
just kind of look like a golden
retriever that retired from sniffing out
drugs just to do them
um
Cody what do you uh what do you think
about uh dating in Austin have you been
on a lot of dates I've been on quite a
few dates and I can say with recent
experience uh being ghosted is far
better than being stood up
no because when you're stood up you make
plans and you go to the location and
then the person stands you up
salty about dog
what the [ __ ] happened bro what happened
man seven o'clock who was this ass who
has this [ __ ] who did this to you who
did this this person and messed back and
forth for the day talking to the
microphone so people can hear you person
talked online for a day and a half
message back and forth we're in the area
together how about lunch at Mexican
restaurant nearby so you've been
rejected you've been rejected so much
that you you're now able to
differentiate between different types of
rejection damn yeah the dating world is
Harsh out here guys it's [ __ ] harsh
what about a date that went well what's
what usually happens on those uh usually
we have a good time and we agree to go
on another date in the future as it
usually with chicks that live in East
Austin
and got there on a bird scooter
[Music]
I don't have enough data points to say
usually but at least once I referred to
them as data points right now dude
there's a lot of kind of nerdy [ __ ] was
that dude we got a data point right here
in Tiffany C
I'm gonna log this date into his Excel
after this dude
like all right this was a negative
here's everything I said let me
calculate this real quick and throw it
into the calculator Isabel you were
really good at calling dog energy in
people that was awesome I was gonna say
the same thing and you uh hit it right
off the head with the golden retriever
energy what kind of energy does Hans
have
like a dog or just yeah dog energy our
animal yeah what's his spirit animal
let's go
a giraffe for you a giraffe yeah you
know how big those dicks are yeah he's
got a huge dick for an Asian guy
thank you Isabel I'll remember your name
this time don't ask
I'm gonna take that as a compliment
hopefully the spots aren't indicators of
disease or
I'm like a weird weirdly shaped person
um Cody what uh what do you think about
uh dating girl what what what animal do
you look for when you're trying to date
a girl
homo sapien
all right that was a little weird animal
what spirit animal are you attracted to
uh
I don't know I like a free spirit so
like maybe a bird or something a bird
you want to [ __ ] a bird what a pervert
[Laughter]
this guy's over here [ __ ] chickens
and [ __ ]
that's cool is uh Isabelle
what uh what uh what was College like
for you were you like a sorority girl or
were you more like
community college girl okay
dropped senior year so I feel like that
makes me like a little different you
know you're so different Isabel you
spent all that money and have no degree
no I dropped the sorority oh you're
drunk oh you graduated yeah I I did
graduate
and then I went to grad school so are
you Delta cap what was it what sorority
did you go I just find you I'll find you
all right yeah it doesn't matter
that's cool what uh what was dating like
in the sorority and why did you quit
okay well those are two very different
questions I quit because it was too
expensive and I told them that it was
because my grandma died and I had to fly
to her funeral and they still iced me
out afterwards so kind of shitty [ __ ]
how long was your grandma's funeral that
you had to drop out of a sorority for a
whole semester
foreign
my grandma lived in another country so I
had to I'm sure that isn't a sore
subject let's give it up for Isabel what
a what a nice lady out here sharing her
stories
well I'm glad you quit sword is our
Colts and it's good to be an independent
thinker instead of giving your logical
mind over to people that are just gonna
use it to [ __ ] each other
um Cody what do you think about
fraternities I have no real opinion I
think they're just a weird Club
I like to get drunk with a bunch of frat
members like old friends and stuff like
that out of college and I like to make
them teach me my uh their secret
handshake I'll be like I'll never
[ __ ] tell you guys and then I tell
[ __ ] everybody it was hard to put it
on Tick Tock it's [ __ ] hilarious
viral yeah
it's a good story that was awful I'm
sorry you guys what the [ __ ] that's
great my input was horrible there you're
doing great Gareth
Isabel so uh what do you look for in a
spirit animal when you're dating someone
oh
is the question what spirit animal do I
look for okay
um
honestly like a golden retriever would
be good for me I think yeah okay yeah
yeah do you bite people Cody that's kind
of not unless they ask
oh
Cuddy
Cody what's the freakiest thing you've
done in bed
uh probably
um
one lady really didn't want to hear his
response
hot wax and ice huh you waxed a woman's
no you didn't care well no we played
with hot bikes
butthole I just wanted to say but what
kind of animal is that that's like a
[ __ ] Tourette's Doberman
what
I don't know man
butthole I didn't tell you dude I could
not tell you falling apart no no no no
I've got it all together dog oh how do
you say you poured hot wax on someone
yeah and then where does the ice come in
uh before and after just we gotta ice
the wound very cold and dead very hot or
very comparatively hot compared to the
ice interesting so it's like a
temperature fetish I wouldn't call it a
fetish but yeah it was just
two three times I mean not everyone does
it yeah
I think have you ever have you ever like
heated people up or cooled them down
just to get them sexually excited
oh I don't need tricks like that oh [ __ ]
damn Isabella
independent and she knows
what she's all right Hans
Isabel what does uh what is like uh like
anything like that you you don't you
don't do any like hot wax or anything
that's I'm not going to answer that
I'm not going to talk about it says she
lets him Marvin Gaye well yeah I mean we
don't have to talk about sex that's more
of like a little bit topic for me so but
I respect you opening up
you said I've been on this show Too Much
note yeah
how did the hot wax and Ice go over like
um I think fairly well the only kind of
Hiccup was you got to be careful because
it's a pain in the Hat I don't want to
hear about it
he said it's a pain in the ass to clean
the sheets yeah wax and sheets is hard
to get out
so you gotta make sure your aim is good
put it all on the body yeah don't spill
or put out cloth that you can maybe
sacrifice put out a tarp yeah get your
sexy tarp out or a towel the towel is
nice too
it just has to be one you're okay with
throwing away or they're being waxed
stuck on it almost perpetually because
it doesn't come out wait I have
something logistical questions okay um
so what do you do with the wax once it's
been dripped uh so like do you rip it
off is that part of the sex kind of yeah
it's more of a gentle peeling if you've
ever spilled like a wax candle on
yourself and peeled the wax off because
I know it's not like hair waxing wax no
no no no no this is very candle wax and
it's warm so it's always very soft you
look like a guy that would have a lot of
candle wax on his fingers
applies tugging Sensations it's hot and
then there's ice to make it cold and
it's just different
thank you for describing that yeah
you guys look like you guys could go to
yoga together
I mean yeah sure cool Black Swan yeah
okay
let's do it get some let's go you guys
let's go we're seeing it happen you guys
they're gonna do it second date
happening get some kombucha after the
day after the yoga class
okay is he gonna get a second date I
don't know oh shut the [ __ ] up please
think about it you know I'm sorry well
I'm I'm gonna hang out after this for
the open mic if so if you want to hang
out afterwards I'll be around all right
good to know all right give it up for
Isabelle and Cody
let's go Cody
a beekeeper and a consultant
we got some more names in the bucket
we got Taiwan coming up
Ty
also the lady of the evening please
y'all give it up for Tiffany M
Tiffany M Tiffany Tiffany
wait 30 seconds that's you
or even twice we'll redraw sorry guys
Uno Moss
all right please give it up for Ashley
hey me I think oh yeah Ashley H Ashley h
should be fun this is being live
streamed
so
okay maybe no don't give it out online
maybe unless you want to okay look her
up her name is Ashley Harvey Ashley
Harvard what's your social security
number
credit card information too all right 60
seconds on a date with Ty went starting
now hi Ashley so did your friend brought
you here did my friend yeah I actually
brought her here oh really
oh because you knew that she needed some
D in her life
yeah yeah
oh so are you uh a dating consultant
dating consultant no her dating
consultant
oh this is a free woman
okay okay
um so I actually brought my friend here
the two Hispanics
those are my people oh really oh I got
them across the border
yeah
yeah that's like brother
yeah
I'm a part-time immigration attorney
I need some
something oh you need some people
um you know my slogan if um I can if I
can get me in I can get you in too I
like that yeah ten times give it up for
a comedians
going on a date with uh tip uh Ashley
Harvey
wow Thomas are you unedible too Taiwan
is about to defend his woman right now
he's a very messy Audi fan any woman
hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah Ty what a feminist
what a male feminist
I didn't know you were a white knight
dazzles on his shirt
yeah you see what it says
says I'm from Pflugerville [ __ ]
hell yeah
it's a flugerville pride in the room
tonight yeah
um actually a fan came to my house show
yesterday and they gave me this shirt so
it felt great nice you're running a show
in your house what is that like
um you know
um different people go there and I have
couples go to my shows
um she doesn't watch me do comedy if
that's what y'all thinking uh it's a
comedy show at my house it might never
wait what what did you think that they
were thinking and I guess that's swing a
party or something
hey you want to come to my show it's in
my house and the show's mostly my dick
dude that's half of my Act
that's pretty interesting yeah it must
be a pretty short Act
okay some people say it's a act that
stretch
oh
it's long and thin
if y'all don't know Ty he's a local
Legend in Austin uh You Gotta Give It Up
and also go check out his [ __ ]
YouTube page because it's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] PornHub uh
yeah
they aren't as good looking
the first Asian porn star Taiwan no I
think that's a that's Asian porn star
before definitely yeah hilarious
exaggeration okay I did not get that at
all
[Music]
yeah sounds sarcastic a lot of people
aren't getting a lot of things tonight
um oh damn
Ty so you said you got people across the
border I didn't realize you were half
immigration attorney half coyote
[Laughter]
well you know you have to have a side
hustle everybody have a side Hustle
do you have a side hustle Ashley
no I want to though you want to see
passive income oh yeah show me the way
yes so you have sell merch I have the
equip keep addiction that's my merch
yeah yeah yeah he bought it up for 20
bucks this is I actually got her first
only fans account
I've considered
hell yeah what kind of like my
my body okay your feet are part of your
body but that's true but so it's your
feet your most stunning feature is that
why
they're they're they're petite they're
cute but
they're the features they're more like
modest I would rather not show the other
kids yeah feet are easy that's for like
you know behind closes I feel like real
perverts are in defeat okay like I don't
think that average dude let me see them
[ __ ] toes I feel like them Honkers I
wanna sniff them hey speak for yourself
girl I feel like oh I was about to say
the same thing I said yeah I feel like
you and two feet do you have a foot
fetish
um no I don't okay are you lying no why
why not about that that's true because
you're from Pflugerville [ __ ]
don't you come outside
that's the hit that's the tag I'm sorry
that's doing references to songs that
nobody knows I know the [ __ ] out of that
song and my friends also know that song
and love you Ty so just getting drunker
and drunker it's two drinks and Edibles
and Edibles hey you pick a bad choice of
selecting the second host Ty are you
making a play to uh take over my show
um no I'm not Mongolian
[Laughter]
this Chinese that's why that's funny
it's getting my race wrong
so some Asian and Asian violence
uh yeah you bust out your calculator
I'll bust out mine oh I had ninja stars
like in the back I mean I have nothing
to say y'all whooped our ass in Vietnam
um so I asked me what ethnicity are you
it was a good time
we're not John go ahead what was your
question Oh What ethnicity are you what
do you think
take a guess
Hispanic ding ding ding yep there's a
few other ones okay well a brown person
in Texas is Hispanic who would have
guessed I know look at you
um you're a you're a two Texas three
other ones three other ones yeah
your Mexican
no Hispanic is different from Mexican
Hispanic is like Mexican Puerto Rican
and more I think she knows that
I'm like do I know that though I'm like
hold up
sticking down
Mexican
are you single
am I single yeah he's trying to see if
she's black or not what what what I mean
damn people are usually in relationships
sometimes the matter okay
what is she single how is what does that
have to do with the race
it does and I'm trying to keep a
conversation going
well the conversations
oh Vietnamese yeah how do you know yeah
yeah you know I'm not Vietnamese
um my best friend
oh wow that's awesome we always have
something in common wow yeah I remind
you your best friend
yeah
yeah like um like faux yeah enough oh it
won like every week I
like yeah especially this time of year
oh yeah so good another good one is cold
and when the weather is raining I don't
like cold Pho but no I'm talking about
the weather
I don't I don't buy it and wait 30
minutes till it's cold and I eat it
wow that's some serial killer [ __ ] right
there it's somebody sit there and wait
for the fall to go cold that's the time
that you have to leave before the photon
code
I was like that's backwards yeah
so are you from like straight Vietnam
I mean can you tell by my voice
a little bit Yeah I came here when I was
five
yeah my dad was in the Vietnam War
and uh he won
I [ __ ] knew it I thought none of
y'all laughed and I was [ __ ] right
okay wait my uncle lost his legs in that
war all right all right he won because I
mean he lost a battle but he won the war
you know uh I'm not probiot no more okay
I'm gonna let that none of y'all laughs
I mean that's the reason how I got here
on an airplane so he lost the battle
that was the Vietnam War yeah won the
war which was coming to America yep so
yeah America sent an airplane for us
which was pretty cool yeah it's a very
secretive thing I wish I could have sent
an airplane for your Mexican friends
over there
um you know they had to take the bus
yeah I sent a greyhound
yeah oh he's whammy I give him a scuba
gear
that's funny that uh you said that they
came in a greyhound because uh coyote is
kind of a greyhound and you're their
coyote so think about that for a little
minute yeah uh Ashley what's uh your
favorite thing to do on a date
hmm I like to be spontaneous I like to
like laugh a lot what would you do
spontaneously with Thai
oh man that was bad you guys
oh my there was an eye rolling
everything oh my God this is pretty
spontaneous
I would say this is pretty sweet yeah
it's very spontaneous yeah yeah very
nice inducing
yeah yeah I'm not sure what I'll do with
UniFirst today oh yeah I took out you
some fall yeah yeah
spots some hot no cold some hot or warm
or cold
medium temperature faux so what do you
uh like to what do you like to like give
girls besides faux like maybe a bon me
sandwich
I mean you know after we have a couple
bowl of fall and it goes well maybe
that's so the bond me is like third date
material yeah they don't get to buy me
right away
uh you make him wait for it yeah that's
messed up I want that first date
oh you went on the first day
oh he almost got you there he uses
Vietnamese trickery yeah
actually I went to an all Asian
oh really
part like majority Asian Ronnie were you
in North Korea
Georgia what so far from North Korea
yeah I didn't know there was a all Asian
school in Georgia
Chinatown yeah why were you knitting
there why yeah my
my parents I didn't have an option
just happened that way okay yeah
so you had a knob Asian friends blowing
out
yeah nice I have enough Mexican friend
too culture yeah I have a lot of Mexican
friends
well you can for 15 an hour over by the
Home Depot oh man
um so now you know how much those guys
suck dicks for
hell yeah hello
some corn on the cob
actually so you're Hispanic and you know
Ty's willing to cook you a bond me after
three dates
how many days does it take to eat your
burrito
[Laughter]
and chipotle
like where you don't you don't know how
to cook any Hispanic food
um I'm like I'm not a real Mexican you
know a fake Mexican what is the real
Mexicans think about this Mexican
exactly
it means that I don't speak Spanish like
you know that's not my first language
I'm a yeah it's a little bit
disappointing when I meet well then she
told me like aren't you Spanish you
should be able to speak it I'm like well
it's American Dream
learn as few languages as possible
I'm content with just in English but I'm
all you know what do you think Thai yeah
I mean
um I think it makes sense she doesn't
speak Spanish because she was raised
around Asian
told her not to know in Spanish
um so what did you do for a living I'm
an executive assistant for a Healthcare
Company wow that sounds very Prestige
right yeah I am trying to leave oh
you're trying me yeah it's your
Healthcare Company to where where you
think about jumping ship to
um the unknown I don't know yet you
don't know yet yeah yeah it's not mid
life
yeah how old are you to have a crisis
um 25 25. wow if you're gonna die at 50.
it's called a quarter life crazy
yeah yeah quarter life I don't know if
it's a crisis but it's more like a
realization of like I don't know if I
want to do this forever yeah yeah I
don't know if I want to make fabulous
amounts of money and live in a nice
place
I mean yeah wow yeah I've been having a
hard time with that money's not
everything you guys oh it's great they
really are not Hispanic well it's great
that you say that that money is are you
really Asian
is
well you said it that was an odd
question to ask or ask Hans Kim
are you Asian Hans Kim
who's more Asian do you think me or Ty
if we had an Asian battle wait wait time
out there has to be a bracketed system
who do you think is more Asian Gareth
Fisk or Hans Kim first off
are you asking me yes
it's more Asian me me or Hans
what do you guys think
what another question yeah you just
asked the dumbest question ever
this is a slam dunk Taiwan is the most
Hispanic person on this stage right now
Hot Tamales muy bien
wow you speak Spanish better than you
speak English
hahaha
Ty do you ever like pull off a move
where you're like oh you know how to say
this in Vietnamese let me teach you and
then they love like learning from you
uh that never happened never
you could do that though that sounds
like a porn
[Laughter]
Ashley what did you uh what did you
think about the date and what do you
think about uh you know like dates in
general with Vietnamese men
something
that same thing
y'all would have expected that to come
out of my mouth huh
no a little pale Vietnamese man what's
wrong with it nothing wrong with it I'd
hope not
I am not pale
am I no I'm saying Chinese people
beautiful okay love you yeah
yeah
you guys come on give it up for time
[ __ ] sick
beautiful man Ashley do you think you'll
buy a piece of his merch tonight Crypt
Keeper's dick
uh I think I'm gonna pass on that one
what about I'm from Pflugerville [ __ ]
keep it around in case
friends
yeah yeah cool yeah
have you ever been to Pflugerville
you know what I don't think I have do
you want to they have a nice Panda
Express there
what do they have at Pflugerville like a
water tower
no yeah that's what I've heard yeah
Friday Night Lights is in flugerville
dude what are you talking about man it's
a Texas tradition good old football
all right nobody Suburban ain't nothing
there whatever
if you had to take Ashley anywhere in
Pflugerville where would you take her in
Pflugerville
I would take her
to Cinemark Theater
Cinemark Theater yeah that's like the
only thing to do there damn go to the
movie A Pflugerville classic yeah the
Cinemark they have great seats okay
it's like right like reclining legacies
to play a bun and then like the Feet
Store come out
it's like the recliner ones yeah
you can order a few yeah okay so yeah
you know all the riches Pflugerville has
to offer with the princess
hey what can I say I'm from a small City
where are you from Pflugerville
[ __ ]
give it up for a Time Ashley yeah
great stuff y'all
that was the show thank you so much
Gareth what do you think about all these
beautiful dates that we saw dude I
thought we saw some Sparks Fly tonight
that was [ __ ] sweet like there was
some fun times up on the stage tonight
what do you think and it's all recorded
check it out on youtube.com check out
Gareth Fisk he's a real Texan
thanks guys my name is Garrett Fisk uh
catch me on Instagram Gareth from Texas
uh I'm from Austin and Texas in general
so uh also give it up for my good friend
Hans Kim y'all thank you so much for
being here now that is so impossible
without this guy thank you so much for
coming out drive safe good night tip
your bartenders a lot they're the [ __ ]